coming up next week at the Strasburg
plenary lots of special guests more
grilling speakers and a little something
called the State of the Union
Google welcome to be gender the last
year have had its fair share problems
terrorism a refugee crisis n-now a
looming brexit for many an observer the
EU is in a precious situation can the
commission president convinced the world
that he is the right man to study the
ship news speech last year the Ease
first elected commission president
talked about having greater unity and
honesty but instead of citizens getting
closer to the EU British people voted to
leave it mister UK to show a faltering
EU is not failing no doubt you'll bring
his honest eaters they to speech but can
he deliver real solutions well one of
the things that mr. Janka has done in
reaction to the growing terrorism threat
is to create a new commissioner
portfolio an anti-terrorism and showing
a sense of humor despite a brexit the
man tasks for the job is British back in
March missing a court for a security
Union following the attacks in Brussels
with the resignation of jumpin Hill as
Commissioner for financial services and
with every member state needed to be
represented at a commission level the
incumbent British ambassador to France
the Judean King has been put forward as
a commissioner designate the security
union will any bees choose to anoint the
UK's latest offering the hearing takes
place on Monday with a vote on his
candidacy on Thursday Parliament's car
emissions inquiry committee set up in
the wake of the VW diesel Jeep will vote
on an interim report on Tuesday but not
before they request the presence of more
commissioners to give evidence at a
meeting of the MS committee on Monday
find out what the internal market
commissioner Elisabetta VN kowelska
and de carmen Avella the Commissioner
for Environment to have to say and now
for some news in brief the EU Commission
took a bite out of apples smacking it
with a 13 billion euro fine for unpaid
taxes to ireland new heights for the
commission as it sticks to its promise
to fight corporate tax avoidance
representatives from the Commission will
be in Strasbourg to get any Peas an
update
on Apple MEP s will discuss recent
infractions of fundamental rights on
Tuesday and vote on a non-binding
resolution on Wednesday this session
brings Holiness the 14th Dalai Lama to
Strasburg find out what he has to say to
any pedes or the Foreign Affairs
Committee on Thursday the author of a
parliamentary report says the EU has
neglected social rights of EU workers
and calls for legislation to be
strengthened any peace debate report and
vote on it on Thursday
this year's g20 summit has been quite
eventful there's been a diplomatic spats
between the US and China and also been a
subject of verbal abuse the US President
Barack Obama canceled a meeting with the
President of the Philippines
despite the shenanigans are both China
and the u.s. signed off on the Paris
climate change agreement but no deal was
reached between Russia and the US in
Syria and no promises make the UK on a
potential UK US trade deal MEP s will
digest a two-day session of heads of
states on Tuesday and that's all we have
this agenda take care and enjoy the week